So yesterday I did a story about the impending
crisis that has Donald Trump's internet, right
Mr Ship, executive order draft.
Some of the details, uh, have leaked and we're
learning more and more about the horrors of
that executive order.
And fortunately, and I'm actually glad to
see this, this story is getting more and more
attention.
A lot of people reacting to my clip more than
110,000 views in the first 12 hours.
I got dozens of emails, more than 2000 comments
on that video.
And even beyond that, I, I'm thrilled to see
that this story is getting pickup because
it's not like the sexiest, most salacious
story.
It's not necessarily the story that would
get the most attention, but it is an authoritarian
nightmare.
And people are noticing and put simply, this
is how the authoritarian start to use the
law to control speech and to enforce speech.
And you might remember, I was actually thinking
this morning as I was reading about the reaction
to this executive order proposal, Canadian
intellectual Jordan Peterson rose to prominence
for what he claimed was his protest of possible
compelled speech.
By the Canadian government.
He should be right here protesting what Donald
Trump is doing.
Because Donald Trump's drafted executive order
would compel social media networks to half
to allow speech that the Trump administration
determines his so-called political speech
and specifically conservative political speech
to fight back against what they claim is some
kind of extreme liberal bias in social networks
and on platforms.
Uh, Donald Trump believes that social media
platforms are in a biased way suppressing
and blocking conservative speech.
The basis for this is a fantasy, but it doesn't
change that this is extremely dangerous.
It is overwhelmingly authoritarian.
The White House shouldn't have the power to
select and choose what content has to be allowed
on social media platforms.
It is stunning that people like me, social
left Libertarians end up defending the rights
of corporations against the oppressive authoritarian
takeover of speech that Donald Trump wants
to do.
So let me do my impression now of a center,
right?
Libertarian social networks are private companies.
They have to follow non-discrimination law.
Twitter can't say no whites allowed on our
platform.
Youtube can't say no Jews allowed to upload
videos or whatever.
There is already established law that prevents
that Twitter can say, we don't allow the n
word.
We don't allow bullying trans people by deliberately
mis-gendering them over and over and over
again or whatever.
This is all legal content, strictly speaking,
which a private corporation can choose to
allow or not to allow based on their business
priorities, their social priorities or for
whatever reason they want.
As long as it does not violate existing anti-discrimination
laws.
This doesn't mean I like it.
It just doesn't mean they always make the
decisions I would make.
This doesn't mean that it couldn't conceivably
cause me problems, the likes of which we've
been having on youtube, but we can't be hypocrites.
What Trump wants to do is to give the FTC
the federal trade commission power to go after
platforms that the White House believes are
suppressing content on the basis of political
orientation on their platforms, and the scariest
part is that it's believed that there will
be penalties for this against the platforms.
What those penalties will be.
We don't yet know how far does this go.
Do Youtube channels with a million subscribers
become subject to similar restrictions in
a year.
When the David Pakman show youtube channel
hits a million subscribers, if things continue
the way they're going, can the government
say this channel is suppressing certain political
opinions of the right?
Can we be find, can you suffer penalties and
I avoid slippery slope arguments in most cases
because they don't make sense.
This is one of those cases where we really
need to think of the slippery slope who counts
as a possible regulatee of this executive
order?
When do we go from regulating platforms to
regulating individual shows?
This is the biggest attack on a free press
since sort of all the other attacks we've
seen under Donald Trump, but this is a really
big one.
If you care about a free press, I don't care
if you're left or right, you must oppose this.
This is the exact type of heavy handed media
regulation that we see under real bonafide
authoritarians in dictatorships in on a spectrum,
right?
Going from a actual dictatorships to just
countries with leaders that are authoritarian
to the extreme.
China, North Korea, Venezuela, Russia, whichever
version or flavor of authoritarianism you
want to pick out, it's actually difficult
to put into words how dangerous this is.
If this happens, we become a country where
the government can do mass censorship on the
basis of political orientation or of whatever
it wants.
It lets the party in power decide which speech
is allowed on the Internet, which speech must
be allowed on the Internet, on specific platforms.
And this is extraordinarily dangerous.
Now, I'm going to keep talking about this
because it has to be stopped.
And ultimately it may be a court that decides
whether the eventual version of the executive
order that is signed by Trump is legal.
But that means that we have to change who's
choosing the judges.
It's Donald Trump right now.
Increasingly, this is a justice system, a
judiciary controlled by Donald Trump.
More and more to supreme court justices.
25% of appellate and Superior Court, uh, judges.
This is not about whether you like or dislike
Trump.
We know how Trump will use this, but Trump
will be gone in two or six years.
Do Republicans want a future Democratic president
telling the FTC what speeches allowed on the
Internet?
This is straight out of the authoritarian
dictator's playbook.
It has to be stopped.
I'm glad it's getting attention and we're
going to continue talking about it.